the overall idea that if you just let
people talk it will be this pit of
racist pandemonium is it as i said i
think it's sort of childish and it
oversimplifies but it is a great
justification for having a lot of power
over speech i have nickel SP with reason
TV and today we're talking with Gregg
lukien off of fire the foundation for
individual rights in education and the
author of a great new book called
unlearning Liberty campus censorship in
the end of American debate Greg thanks
for joining us thanks Riley very quickly
tell us what fire does well fire has
been around since 1999 we were founded
by Alan Charles cores of Penn and Harvey
silverglade who's a civil liberties
attorney I'm in order to defend free
speech due process and basic rights on
campus we've taken the lead in fighting
speech codes and drawing attention to
them and one hundreds of our education
over the years and then the book on
learning Liberty is obviously very much
about it Adria it's really set on
college campuses across the country and
you talked about in the subtitle as the
end of debate one of the themes in the
book which is very interesting is that
you talk about how people think that we
had a fight over free speech and
political correctness and free speech
one the news you're delivering is that
couldn't be further from the truth it's
completely wrong there was this
political correctness craze in the in
the 80s and early 90s and then all these
speech codes rose up and and the rise of
the speech codes were I mean essentially
what speech codes were saying is that
certain types of expression certain
types of thinking right wrong and must
be eliminated from the college
environment talk about what are the
types of speech that are typically you
know considered beneath you know
allowing even in a university setting
where everything is supposed to be open
for debate right well the interesting
thing is what it started out with in the
80s with the justification for speech
codes were typically racist or sexist
speech but is gone so far afield but in
a way that any First Amendment lawyer
could it could have predicted when you
make rules vague and broad the
administration starts using them just a
police speech that's critical of them
that they don't like not to go after
students they dislike and this is
completely foreseeable at the start of
speech goes movement so nobody should
really be surprised we've reached a
point that just being critical of the
administration is suddenly violating a
speech code well you know in the book
about kind of the great watershed moment
or i guess i should say water buffalo
moment for the creation of fire the
foundation for individual rights on
education happened at the university of
penn and its kids known as the water
buffalo incident briefly recap that and
then kind of explain how that set the
tone for what we're seeing on campus
sure well in the late 80s university
started adopting speech codes and one of
the great opponents of campus speech
codes is alan charles cores and he was
at penn when in 1993 a student was woken
up by a african-american sorority
outside that was serenading the dorms
and in fact the entire dormitory was
woken up and serenading i mean they were
in a pledge week or something yet where
they're chanting and screaming very loud
exactly i just generally being obnoxious
and he yells out the window go home you
water buffaloes and they bring help him
up on charges of racial harassment with
the whole world mystified as to how on
earth is water buffalo a racial epithet
he was trying to insult them rob but
anybody we wasn't it was there's nothing
racial about it and this became a sort
of an international symbol of how off
course universities have gotten with
regards to free speech one of the things
you're talking about a lot in the book
is that universities you know they they
just trampled on due process or many of
them don't even really have what would
be considered due process where they
investigate claims you know fairly and
figure out what was going on most of
them they're kind of verdict first trial
later right what's a more typical case
at a public university that you deal
with it's such an incredibly mixed bag i
mean definitely we've seen an uptick in
free speech zone cases in the past
couple years which is funny like texas
tech university they talk about where
they limited free speech to 120 foot
wide gazebo I know this is on a campus
that's hundreds of acres yeah and the
mountains you can say anything you want
you can think anything you want but you
have to be in a gazebo that's the size
of a small hotel room yeah exactly 20
feet wide and so I don't think any do
any normal person would say that's
constitutional it's obviously not you
can't even fit 28,000 students into a 20
foot 10 but these came up this came up
again the summer university of
cincinnati a libertarian student group
they were trying to circulate a petition
I'll right-to-work ballot petition and
they were told that they needed to give
10 days advance notice if they wanted to
petition
government for redress of grievances and
that they would have to limit it to
point one percent of campus their tiny
little free speech zone they didn't
enforce us across the board for other
students and they even told the students
that if they were seeing quote unquote
walking around campus they would be the
police would be called on them now
private university is it slightly
different right because they make an
either implicit or explicit contract and
say you can come here it's a private
organization so you have to follow our
rules right so people can say you know
what we give up some of our First
Amendment rights right so how does fire
and in the book the cases that you
talked about how do you deal with
private universities our stance on
private universities is one of the
reasons why I was attracted to fire
because they actually have the most
coherent answer to how you deal with
private universities and it's simply
holding them to the way they present
themselves and the promises they make in
their in their materials so Yale and
Harvard they you know get billions of
dollars in donations they get the best
and brightest of both faculty and
students and they present themselves and
in their materials and and into the
world as a citadel of freedom of speech
and free expression so they are
absolutely thinking and free this is
where you go to have your mind blown we
have been to learn the frontiers or the
next great developments in in human
cognition exactly a yale yale has
beautiful language into the policies
talking about mentioning than measurable
thinking the unthinkable this really
bold conception that stems from a mid 70
statement by C Vann Woodward been a
prominent yale historian and it was
really kind of that that statement set
the tone for a lot of American academia
coming out of the 60s of saying you know
what these are places where you know the
whole point is to remove yourself from
the hurly-burly and hustle and bustle of
everyday life whether it's commerce or
religious or whatever and you come to a
place where you can really sit down and
think exactly talk a little bit about
how nothing could be further from the
truth well I had a whole chapter in the
book and I able ta land Harvard
partially because I run into this
argument sometimes like who cares about
these other little state schools and I'm
like no no this is also happening at
Yale and Harvard two of the most famous
schools in the world really Yale had
actually been pretty good and for almost
my entire time at fire until something
happened it might have just been there
added the wrong administrator or
something but as of 2008 they've been
lousy and in 2008 you have two different
cases one in which the university
intervened
and told the student government that
they couldn't have a Fitzgerald quote on
i'll have scott Fitzgerald in my opinion
all Harvard men are sissies rum and they
were wrote we agree and this was a
t-shirt that Yale traditionally puts
together they they come up with a
t-shirt to make fun of Harvard before
the Harvard Yale football game and on
Harvard does the same thing to Yale and
and usually they're really vulgar and in
this case they went with something that
was pretty pretty tame and the
administration came out strongly saying
that that this is unacceptable and in
this it was the idea that sissies was
making fun of gays or lesbians which
points to a lot of the problems in the
way we talk to each other the sort of
like failing of discourse because one in
context that was not at what had the way
Fitzgerald meant it because the full
line is all Harvard men are sissies like
I used to be he's not saying he was
formally get that was not the way the
students intended it and that was not
the way it's usually used at least among
you know people under 40 today it's more
or less of an anachronistic joke and at
the same time this was going on the
university had actually intervened to
prevent a book called the cartoons that
shook the world that was specifically
about the Mohammed cartoons to ban them
from showing any image of Mohammed even
ones that had never been controversial
in the past so if something happened in
2008 yell turned a corner and it's been
pretty reliably bad and that the
cartoons that shook the world book is
fascinating because the scholar who
wrote that and published it with Yale
University Press which is you know a
highly regarded president course
insisted in contractual work that the
images would be right reproduce and then
the University stepped in after the
publishing house had cleared the
manuscript yep so so we're left you know
with Yale a citadel of higher learning
and a boundless knowledge and you know
mentioning the unmentionable trying to
publish or squelch publication of a book
where you can't talk about the things
the book is about exactly one the reason
why I wrote the book was because I
talked about all these insane cases of
students getting in trouble for it in
many cases incredibly tame speech but
I've increasingly over the years gotten
the sort of like yeah but so big deal
you know universities are a little bit a
little bit heavy-handed I mean this is
just the equivalent of having smoking
bans on campus or drinking bands or
something people that have come become
way too comfortable and way to use to
use of this and I and I make the larger
argument that harms
Society in two distinct ways one of them
is the reason for the title unlearning
limiting what I was on a NPR show just
this week and hearing about students
saying I don't know speech isn't that
bad sure we have to get ten days advance
notice in order protest sure we have to
do it in this tiny little zone but
they're pretty fair even-handed about
how they do that and I like no no that's
unconstitutional we're learning to
accept the government telling you where
you can protest how you can protest in a
way that a previous generation would
have utterly unrightfully rejected so
it's a long-term threat to our overall
freedom if people don't get that they
have rights in the first place higher
education is supposed to be a place
where you seek out people that you
disagree with for engagement and
discussion that can actually be
cultivated as the great intellectual
habit that it actually is if you get in
trouble for having their own opinion so
what I think is actually happening on
campus is not so much that people are
changing their minds due to censorship
they're just not talking about what they
believe or they're talking to people
they already agree with so this helps
explain why despite the kind of
overarching most people certainly on the
right and I think a lot of people in the
center would say never the past 30 years
the left has really taken over the
Academy and yet the country has kind of
veered towards the center if not the
right so I mean what you're saying is
that these attempts at mind control
right are not working you get people to
shut up but you don't actually get them
to think different right any and we're
still you're actually encouraging people
to put themselves in echo chambers on to
talk to the people they already agree
with so in that sense kind of like
that's one of the things that's wrong
with our society is we don't have you
know the smart people who disagree
talking to each other they hate each
other did universities have speech codes
before say you know 1985 or 1990 I never
I've never claimed that there was a
golden age for free speech on college
campuses and and that definitely you
know I jock that there might have been a
perfect week in 1977 when everything was
great when the old authoritarians were
over over and before political
correctness began but the current kind
of speech codes are the ones that come
more out of the 80s there certainly were
different kinds of restriction bro
speech before that but they largely gone
out of fashion by the 1970s but then
came back into fashion with a whole new
justification but they still end up
doing a lot of ways the same things i
think that there's a huge temptation by
people in power to want to be in charge
of everything that particularly with the
huge expansion of bureaucracies on
campus there's a
lot more people who put themselves in
maternal istic or paternalistic position
and talk about that because this is all
so fascinating gather all the discussion
that people say about higher education
is a being funded well and we're losing
tenure-track lads and research faculty
in fact the great increase in staffer
and faculty are in administration and
this is something that up you know
administrators of course push back
against but it's government reports that
are they're saying so more between 2004
and 2006 the number of people involved
in administration and staff at
universities past the number of people
at universities involved in instruction
and that's just keeps it keeps on
growing and what fire ends up fighting
all the time or it's not you know
usually a faculty we actually defend
faculty it's these mid level
administrators who don't know proper
boundaries don't have any appreciation
for freedom of speech think people some
of the younger people were sort of
scratching their heads about why this
civility pledge that harvard students
were asked to do last year was such a
big deal it pressured them to sign
something that pledged themselves to
count civility kindness inclusiveness on
par with intellectual entertainment and
the interesting thing is kind of like
you know students of the 60s would have
said that you can't make me be nice i
would have yeah literally given the
finger yeah they were to write it what I
mean well and this is also part of the
kind of interesting backdrop of your
work in the book is the idea that if we
don't have these speech codes if we
don't have civility pledges we don't
have honor codes then it's just going to
be pandemonium because everybody going
to school is actually a racist homophobe
yeah poor mannered you know horrible
human being talk a little bit about that
where does that come from and why is
that wrong when I was at Stanford in the
late 90s it was just sort of assumed
that that underneath everybody there was
of this horrible sort of racist bigot
it's really a childish
oversimplification made a bit in my mind
and so you have these really aggressive
programs like the University of Delaware
program that's trying to change people
from stop being so horribly racist
meanwhile you look at the surveys of the
students when they were coming into
Delaware incredibly tolerant incredibly
open-minded what would never regardless
of where they were on the political
spectrum the overall idea that if you
just let people talk it will be this pit
of racist pandemonium is it as I said I
think it sort of
childish and it oversimplifies but it is
a great justification for having a lot
of power over speech and I think that it
becomes so tactically convenient for
people to believe this that they
continue to sort of perpetuate this idea
that we're dealing with a generation
that's much less enlightened that it
actually is this is it's an odd thing so
the University which is where free
speech is supposed to take place
critical inquiry and yours but you don't
really start working your brain yep a
muscle that's being you know you're
being told don't use your brain just
mouth what we tell you how you know from
the residence hall residence life were
from faculty right politically motivated
out in the world though we see this
flowering of a kind of antinomian
anti-authoritarian highly critical of
all claims to knowledge culture whether
you know whether it's south park or
online or whatever you what you're
talking about it in unlearning liberty
is that the university even as it
becomes more central to people's life
plans and is actually becoming less
important to what you're going to end up
doing yeah and I think I talked about
cultivating cheap dodges to debate and
among those I talked about selective up
tightness and selective relativism or
feigned outrage for that matter that
people can go and watch southpark can be
their favorite show that watch Comedy
Central day long but the the rules are
at the University the bar for
offensiveness is set incredibly low so
there's a huge disconnect between the
way people are actually lived their
lives and the way they're taught to
actually talk about things in
universities and a lot of these these
tactics end up really short circuiting
meaningful debate and discussion in the
places where they most need to be
happening fire has a kind of speech cut
of the month and everything and you can
see all of that on the fire org know but
you know where are the schools that are
getting it right well university of
virginia has been very good about
working with fire and the reports at
least that we get is that they actually
do a good job of trying to get people
across lines of difference talking to
each other but overall i think that
there is a shine away most universities
from what we both could really fix the
problem which is this cultivating the
intellectual habit of seeking out the
smart person you disagree with and be
people who are truly educated should
think of this as a duty and and too many
that's too hard frankly i think i think
we've got a very comfortable very
affluent a very expensive academy right
now that's a little a little
uncomfortable with
going to happen if people actually start
talking to each other they might they
might get upset and and they've kind of
forgotten that that's part of the point
that the emotional rigor of actually
expanding your mind or taking on
arguments that may be wrong or taking on
arguments that may change your mind it's
something that there are great Academy
is shying away from alright well we'll
leave it there Greg Luciano thank you
very much for talking with reasontv the
book is unlearning Liberty campus
censorship in the end of American debate
the organization is fire foundation for
individual rights and education which is
online at the fire org and Greg you also
blog at the huffington post correctly so
for reason TV i'm nick gillespie